[Musique]
philippe brillault je vous en prie
installez-vous bienvenus bon je remercie
de nous avoir rejoints pour ce premier
numéro du café politique nouvelle
nouvelle version ici à montigny le
bretonneux vous avez quitté mon team
vous avez quitté le chien mais pardon
pour venir à montigny le bretonneux
puisque vous êtes maire du chesnay je
vais vous présenter un petit peu à côté
du vélodrome pas loin qu'on n'est pas
loin vous êtes maire du chesnay depuis
oui pas de 1890 1900 le siècle dernier
né en bronze n'avait pas de lassitude
bah écoute et apparemment les électeurs
n'ont jamais eu puisque c'est eux qui
décident
moi je propose il décide et je pense que
le propre d'un élu c'est de faire
toujours seul en quoi il croit le jour
on ne croit pu vous arrêter
donc j'y crois encore mais je prépare
bien évidemment la suite ça veut dire la
succession d'une équipe parce que dans
trois ans ou quatre ans si la
prorogation d'un an dans le cadre d'une
future loi
je passerai la main en tant que maître
sse a cédé pour vous c'est le dernier
monde à ça près c'est ce qu'il a fait
oui je considère que mes fais le toi
après c'est le mandat de trop mais c'est
le mandat de trop on n'a pas le droit de
se présenter pour soi on se présente
avant tout pour les autres quand vous
présentez à chaque fois vous n'avez
jamais eu un moment de justement de
doute de se dire est ce que j'ai encore
cette flamme est ce que j'ai encore des
projets est ce que j'ai encore des
choses à défendre avant de prendre la
décision d'y aller effectivement sur ces
questions vont lancer
et puis on sent d'un petit peu les
personnes les dernières les élections
législatives où j'ai été présent il ya
beaucoup de gens qui m'ont dit on n'a
pas voté pour vous pour regarder pour mr
et matin dsk un moment ou un autre
vous allez me lâcher pour que je fasse
quelque chose d'autre comme quand j'ai
arrêté une clientèle médicale les gens
m'ont dit oh là là on vous regrette et
puis il ya ceux qui qui vous aiment
qu'ils lisent bah écoute et bonne chance
voilà on vous laisse aller voilà
vous avez des envies de d'autre mandat
pas de quitter la politique mais
d'évoluer en politique
non je souhaite mettre à profit ce que
j'ai pu apprendre par les autres pendant
plus de 25 ans je pense que c'est ça et
dans trois ans je prépare effectivement
une réflexion sur ce que je ferai ce que
je peux apporter
donc là les trois ans qui viennent c'est
de pouvoir apporter l'expérience et la
connaissance des dossiers à une équipe
ça s'appelle transmettre et puis après
je ferai certainement autre chose qui
correspond à ma ligne de vie
c'est-à-dire les autres par rapport à la
santé par rapport au social ç'a toujours
été ma fibre et cela restera un oui
parce qu'au civil un médecin vous êtes
médecin
professionnellement c'est un bon jour
des médecins même si j'ai arrêté
l'hôpital
et
les complications organisé je continue
toujours les gens viennent me voir
encore pour avoir des affiches on
consulte toujours même si certains ne
pensent pas et voilà je le fais et je le
fais avec plaisir et puis vraiment avec
le souhait d'apporter aux autres un
petit peu quelque chose voilà ça a
toujours été ma fibre
vous avez quatre enfants vie
professionnelle vie familiale bien
remplie pourquoi la politique en plus
c'est ce que s'est engagée sur un manga
de mer c'est quand même assez assez
conséquent et aussi même temps c'est pas
la politique en plus c'est la vie avec
cris c'est à dire que la politique c'est
le prolongement de ce que l'on fait au
quotidien comment peut-on faire de la
politique sans est en lien direct avec
la vie de tous les jours donc avoir des
enfants on parlait tout à l'heure des
enfants et bien les enfants c'est un
vrai moteur enfin je veux dire le
dernier qui vit à la maison
si je l'avais pas j'aurais pas ma revue
de presse l'une est le soir à 23h ou le
matin de bonne heure cc c'est du bonheur
comme wallace et on est toujours
connecté je pense que la vie au
quotidien
c'est la connexion permanente et c'est
donc la proximité on ne peut pas être un
bon élu soit pas de proximité donc la
proximité ça la vie au quotidien
par contre la vie politique n'est pas
toujours facile c'est une vie difficile
il ya des rapports conflictuels parfois
je vous vois sourire on va on va quand
même à évoquer qui sera pas ce que je
veux dire que l'on est en france est une
catastrophe
je veux dire c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
que au mois de juin les gens avec j
un ras-le-bol total on dit hop on met
tous
mais tout à la ben voilà alors avec les
conséquences mais ça s'appelle en termes
anglais je crois un watch out c'est à
dire qu'on nettoie tout et on repart
pour part ça va être effectivement
l'enjeu des semaines et des mois qui
viennent vous en êtes où personnellement
avec votre famille politique
alors où j'en suis où j'en suis que
jaurès tranquillement en tant
qu'observateur magmatique et
d'aujourd'hui du quotidien c'est
regarder écouter et agir dans la
fonction ou dans les fonctions qui sont
les miennes c'est à dire la mairie le
conseil départemental la présidence
partagée avec françois de mazières
l'hôpital de versailles l'hôpital de
millau qui s'enchaînaient donc tous à
une logique autour de l'humain le social
la médecine voilà ensuite ma famille
politique
moi je suis avant tout ce que
j'appellerais alors quand on dit
gaulliste fait conservateur rétrograde
c'est une esprit c'est un esprit qui est
quelque part l'orgueil d'une fonction
l'orgueil d'un résultat l'orgueil d'un
pays
et puis je suis plutôt une droite
sociale voilà moi j'aurais tendance à
dire que qu'est ce qu'il ya dans le
terme droite sociale mais ça veut dire
que c'est un certain nombre d'idées qui
sont contrairement au socialisme le
capital doit être un moteur de valeur
ajoutée pour servir à ceux qui n'en ont
pas et n'ont pas de consommer un capital
pour redistribuer voilà c'est c'est un
axe fondamental pour moi le on a besoin
d'argent pour une économie et cet argent
doit être partagée avec tout le monde
mais avec je parlais de votre famille
politique les rapports ont été plus ou
moins compliquées en veillant à mesure
des années on va parler de pierre bédier
le président du conseil départemental
alors pierre bédier c'est un type
extraordinaire dans sa dynamique dans
son action autres et ce qu'ils écoutent
ils écoutent
non il entend mais ils écoutent pas
toujours et en fait mon désaccord avec
pierre bédier c'est la fusion du 92 78
elle est là et quand on est en désaccord
avec quelqu'un en politique l'essentiel
c'est la loyauté et je pense que c'est
une qualité qu'il faudrait développer
dans la rotonde politique donc comme je
suis loyal djediat pierre je préfère que
des groupes majoritaires il m'a dit
c'est bien c'est nécessaire quand on
n'est pas d'accord donc mais ça
n'empêche pas pour autant qu'il n'a pas
retiré la délégation de tout ce que je
fais au niveau de la santé et que je
continue à être honnête par rapport à ça
voilà c'est tout et je vois bien que la
fusion des départements bas de laine il
semblerait que le plein de la république
et nous deux pour l'instant les
différents échos des différents
ministères sont à l'épargné aux abords à
blaye baladez-vous donc aujourd'hui ça
sera plus une collaboration partage
qu'une fusion sachant que moi je suis
pour supprimer ou le département ou
l'interco et qu'il faut se diriger
peut-être pour supprimer le département
dans trois ans quatre ans voilà donc
parce que je suis conseil départemental
que je dis qu'il faut le supprimer
non je pense qu'elles les couches qu'il
faut super mais avec le conseil
départemental sûrement vous avez des
comparé à des convictions des
engagements que vous menez en a un qui
vous a beaucoup exposé exposé au niveau
national notamment c'est celui de la
manif pour tous ont été en première
ligne le contre le mariage pour tous est
ce que vous avez des regrets par rapport
à ce combat et la façon dont les choses
se sont se sont passées et comme on les
réveille sur la base et oui
des regrets sur mon engagement
certainement pas mon combat c'est tout
simplement la famille et l'enfant
quand j'ai vu que j'étais sur le mur des
homophobes à côté de monsieur poutine
bon ça m'a fait sourire parce qu'en fait
le mot sexualité je travaille avec elle
avec des gens tous les jours des gens
extraordinaires dont j'ai aucun problème
sur le sujet au mal eux sur la chose
essentielle c'est un enfant quelles
peuvent être ses origines pour lui
d'ailleurs parce que en tant que médecin
j'ai vu trop de gens nés sous x qui
toute leur vie trance eu besoin de
connaître leurs origines et
je pense que aussi nous avons une grande
détresse sur les enfants qui sont perdus
dans les familles même d'ailleurs
hétérosexuels ou aux parce que je pense
que le vrai sujet aujourd'hui c'est
l'éducation c'est l'accompagnement des
enfants et on voit bien quand on fait
nos dossiers que le la réflexion autour
des parents devient plus la réflexion
autour de l'enfant donc le vrai sujet
aujourd'hui politique nationale c'est
l'enfant et le jeune le débat sur la pma
revient un petit peu ces derniers jours
ça veut dire que vous allez reprendre
non l'espace combine bénin et allez
allez vous battre et vous engagez vous
aviez aussi fait une pétition à l'époque
hein on a beaucoup parlé de moi avec le
souhait du présent la république ne
relancer la possibilité démocratique de
faire cela on en reparlera j'aurais tout
de suite parlé de la pma la pma elle est
offerte support tant que médecin elle
est offerte à des gens qui ont un
problème
médical pour les femmes pour le faire
donc on l'a bien une capacité de le
faire dans certaines conditions
libérez la pma c'est dangereux puisque à
la limite tout le monde pourra par son
enfant en dématérialisé parce que des
matériels et ce tour laboratoire dans
des cristallise war en choisissant les
gamètes les gènes ou autre je pense que
la pma il faut l'encadrer avec une
commission comme on a une punition pour
l'adoption pour adopter on passe par une
commission eh bien je pense que pour la
pma il faut l'encadrer la même façon et
vont pas dire on est contre la pma de
façon systématique
moi je suis content la pma libre mais
par contre que la pma soit un outil pour
accompagner des personnes en difficulté
je suis je ferme pas la porte
et donc il faut regarder tout cela est
donc effectivement c'est dans ce sens là
que je veux me mobiliserai à titre
personnel vous savez déjà que vous allez
mobile vous mobiliser et bien sûr je
pense que le rôle des élus c'est d'être
contributaires à une loi qui soit qui
corresponde quand il ya eu la loi simone
veil j'aurai des députés j'aurais bien
été ennuyé pour la voter parce que
j'étais médecin et je voyais des femmes
qui mouraient de cette décennie père
frange ans par des avortements illégaux
et de l'autre côté je ne suis pas
favorable à
au souhait de pouvoir virer un embryon
est quelque part en tant que médecin je
veux parenthèses qu est ce qu un
stérilet est ce que c'est pas un
avortement aussi donc quand on va très
noir si vous voulez il faut se poser
toutes ses questions et moi ce que je
souhaiterais c'est que les députés se
travaille bien tous les dossiers nous
écoute avant de prendre décisions à
l'emporte-pièce et sur la loi ivg simone
veil vous auriez voté quoi et je vous
dis je ne sais pas encore je pense que
je pense que je me serais peut-être
abstenus je n'aurais pas voilà j'aurais
fait ce qui est rare pour moi je
considère que nous avons des obligations
de réponse sur ce sujet là je pense que
il ya des cas d'exception entre leucate
conscience de la conscience médical de
médecins aussi ça vous aurez posé sur gt
agression entre duquel six fois aux
urgences une femme arrivée avec une
grossesse qui déclenchait une leucémie
ils vont choisissez la mère ou l'enfant
ben on a choisi l'enfant parce que la
mère avait d'autres enfants c'était un
avortement
voilà c'est mais des questions très très
importante qu'on se pose au quotidien
on en revient sur sur un autre sujet
qu'on a abordé très rapidement tout à
l'heure c'est cette ces questions des
signatures puisque je le disais tout à
l'heure vous avez été exposé pendant ce
combat devenir la manif pour tout ce que
vous aviez organisé cette compétition
sept cent mille signatures initié et
organisé avec président sur les frigides
barjots sept cent mille signatures il en
fallait 500 milles pour saisir le 3 mai
les boîtes aux lettres du shônen quand
même sept cent mille est en fait jean
paul delevoye était président d'une a
refusé lyon que la commission accepte
cette pétition pour protéger l'exécutif
c'était clair puisque nous avons gagné
en première instance au tribunal
adminstratif la reconnaissance de la
pétition
puis a eu un appel de jean paul delevoye
pour le cea la cour d'appel de paris qui
a rejeté mon appel si mal qu'il fait
appel parce que je voulais qu'on traite
la pétition on m'a dit la pétition a les
bonnes mais c'est trop tard pour la
traiter
donc j'ai fait appel pour qu'on la
prenne hélas le taa dit j'annule la
décision du tf qui donnait qu'il culmine
à l'administration voilà parce que le
tribunal serait type n'était pas
compétent pour le premier jugement
donc on est actuellement conseil d'état
or le président de la république qui
souhaite qu'effectivement la pétition
soit un outil
ça va être intéressant donc c'est
toujours pas fini j'appelle ça le scot
de tintin vous savez quand on a fini ça
continue eh ben il a toujours nous avons
toujours une pétition citoyenne au bout
du doigt pour pour terminer cette
émission parce qu'on arrive au bout de
ce quart d'heure des changes
un petit questionnaire liés à
l'actualité je vous demande de choisir
une personnalité ou une autre marine le
pen ou florian philippot on est obligé
de le faire c'était obligé de le faire
on est obligé de choisir vous êtes
obligés d'en choisir bas j'aurais dire
tendance à dire florian philippot neymar
ou cavani sorbonne et marc neymar très
bien et trump ou maquereau macro macron
merci beaucoup philippe brillault maire
du chesnay élu également conseil
départemental café politique a retrouvé
dorénavant le vendredi sur tv 78 puis en
replay sur notre site internet
applications mobiles également merci à
look to you qui nous accueille à
dorénavant pour cette saison
[Musique]
et